ce avec moi j'ai jamais exclu puisque la
complicité j'ai dit dès le premier jour
qu'il fallait envisager cette
possibilité
moi pour l'instant je ne ferme pas du
tout cette piste je continue à penser
que intellectuellement il est tout à
fait envisageable si nathalie un conflit
dans les prochaines semaines on pourrait
peut-être en savoir plus j'espère qui
s'avancera parce que pour l'instant
nouvelle idée du mobile il ya deux
réserves en eau salée pour la mise à
mort d'alexis d'avoir été très violent a
expliqué ceci il ne s'explique pas du
tout sûr mode opératoire qui n'en paient
pour vol mettra dans sa femme on le sait
par l'expérience était légale mais lui
ne dirai rien là-dessus vendu plus de
les choses aberrantes qui sont contrôlés
comme tactile et nie formellement avec
un manège donc finalement à part le
transport du corps qu'il s'attribue
assez précisément le reste tout à fait
ni matic pour vous les prochaines
semaines pourrait parler mais je pense
je pense j'espère qu'avant l'été droit
en cas pour juillet et vacances
judiciaires j'espère qu'il sera entendu
et j'espère pour lui pour nous partie
civile pour la vérité commune au dossier
à toutes les parties qu'il s'expliquera
d'une manière ou d'une autre mais qui s
expliquant comment vont vos clients
aujourd'hui que mes clients ils gérés se
noie dans le travail méthodes comme une
autre pour essayer non pas d'oublier
maintenant avec le ramatuelle
l'earl à mandeure et il souhaite
naturellement de ce dossier avant
c'est-à-dire la des réponses aux
questions fondamentales des victimes les
parties civiles pour quoi comment où et
c est le risque est bien là on sait que
6,2 sinna man sport le juge
d'instruction qui n'ira pas le clôturer
faute de combattants
je ne veux pas parler pas sa liberté ses
2,6 la couture et parce que tout a été
fait à part une reconstitution sur place
ça c'est un axe fondamental et
l'audition de mes clients ils sont sur
calais vite et après de seissan des
assises et le risque ce que débat sur le
fond des choses arriver là si je l'aï
les rebondissements ce qui suspendrait
procès d'assises ça c'est quand même